liam payne came on my podcast
a couple weeks ago
and uh
he was drinking whiskey and i think he
said some things that he probably what
do you say
now um
just you know the alcohol definitely
loosens you up so he went to fight
bieber he said he said he said a lot of
stuff people people were upset i'm not
super in
you know the 1d world but he
people were upset that liam said
that he was the basically the
founding father
of one direction that he was the
inception which he very well could have
been but again i don't know i don't know
the internet he was the inception he was
the he quote unquote first honorary
member of one direction
simon built the group around him that's
what he said i think people were upset
and then to be honest
can we just be honest on the pot
i didn't know that liam payne was in one
direction
when i saw him on your i thought he was
in pe blinders
i said i swear to god i thought he was a
character in being blind and i was like
oh that's cool
the guy's talented 100 very talented
very talented but is he a harry styles
yo harry styles man yeah star star star
if he cuts out with the dresses and [ __ ]
you don't like it i do like some nerf i
do like it
[Laughter]
making fun of me for how i'm dressed
this is unbelievable right now
what are you wearing dude get out of
here okay wait a minute wait a minute
he's a star kid's a star no no harry
styles is a star handsome kid
so that's in my opinion that's part of
being a star so like oh what makes a
star
everything dude i swear to god starting
with the name
interesting yeah
go on that
this is this could sound so [ __ ] just
go this is just good this could sound
really good
on that bro when i would
just who cares dude we don't give a [ __ ]
when i was online
dude when i was in high school i always
felt like my name
had had something to it yup i felt like
it had like a ring
and then what had happened happened and
uh made this brand and it worked and
every i'm not saying i'm a star by any
means but i'm saying
logan no when it comes to making a glo
no when it comes not like not like harry
styles when it comes to making like a
global entity
from the name
to the look yep to the talent yep it all
makes like every single star
chris evans chris hemsworth
chris pine
[Laughter]
yeah and harry styles has it he has the
trifecta okay he's got the talent he's
got the look and he's got the name big
brand
tom cruise
everything
everything when you have it all that's
when you're a real [ __ ] star dude
when people can say your name
zach galifianakis
[Laughter]
might not have it
get back between the ferns fatty
all right all right right come on
hangover
i think i think a lot of it's just i
think it's uh i think genetic i think
it's
the world you were born into i think
there's a lot of luck that comes like
probably his name's harry styles that
has a [ __ ] ring but that's not his
real name what
don't do this
is that i mean there's no way harris
heritage i don't think styles wait
you're serious
harrison styles you think that's his
real name
logan is a wild boy yeah
[Laughter]
oh that's his actual name star
harry popular british alex
exactly alex media there you go
interesting so you think the three
qualities are named now what about what
about work ethic for example like you
put out a video every single day and you
edited that video that's immense amount
of time and commitment to success that's
that's part of it that's
my work ethic makes up for my lack of
talent
that's a nice humble thing to say it's i
mean it
i uh
i i'm
not an incredible singer i'm not an
incredible actor
um i just work really [ __ ] hard and
i'm smart should we bring up some of
your music some of your old music hold
on a second
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
i
got i
he goes it's trash but it's hot trash
yeah talking about his music all right
brother
[Music]
no i thought he won six out of eight
rounds i thought he won six out of eight
rounds that's right
black lives matter i thought he won six
out of eight rounds
black lives matter bro come on stop it